well for those joining us on the live
stream this is another episode in our
continuing efforts to design the future
of chemistry and Wolfram language so
let's get started
where are we starting are we starting
the molecule plot where are we starting
your hard to hear by the way this is no
better okay right so what we talked
about last time
um what an earth for these so let's see
so for the bonds we could have a single
bond double bond triple bond and they
would have escaped patterns that could
could become nice glyphs for in fixed
notation
well that's an interesting claim okay so
let's let's take a look here so what
you're imagining is that we start off
with okay what is string key wasn't
earth is that so that's just an example
like that your person could give a
string as a key a label a key so that
they can refer to the like that later
okay fine fine so the alighted form is
just the standard element abbreviation
here or alternative the element entity
presumably yes like or isotope entity oh
interesting yeah very good
right so something like that now
arguably the canonical form of this
should have entities in it what do you
think about that yeah that's it sounds
good I'm sensible to me I mean how do we
do the second atom then that's carbon-14
as an entity I think we do it the way
you would think you'd do it namely I
think we can just isn't this doesn't
this just gonna work okay great okay
question three but what doesn't work is
giving a charge I don't know that you
can use entity instance to give a charge
to and well an element X would that be
true I mean I don't see any reason why
we shouldn't make that true Michael
reservations for the isotope because the
isotope
not refer to the full atom like it
doesn't refer to the electrons it only
exactly exactly but you are mostly
interested in the nun things inside I
just don't think we should have strings
hanging out there I mean we've got this
nice canonical representation as
entities if we don't have clearly a
canonical representation of atoms as
entities I understand carbon is an
element is quite different from carbon
as an atom okay well should we have
atoms as entities or is that going to
cause other problems I mean it seems not
okay so let's imagine that we have I
mean it is a complicated thing because I
mean carbon it does a bulk material is
one thing go ahead it is maybe a
limiting form of entity instance like we
can take 20 coms of carbon of
conveniently as entity instance and
could think of that once and as empty as
the new unit for counting things has
been approved in the next year's that
then it would be very natural to say an
entity in sense of carbon element with
end goes to one
what the heck is end and it's basically
one over abogado constant it's one sink
and it's allowed for atoms radicals
molecules and there's long list of
things for the truth to be allowed okay
um what does it mean and every one
entity of it okay interesting okay fair
enough I you have ten think told me this
before and I had heard this before but I
keep on forgetting it which is a bad
sign okay but let's so a scene 10 the
end of the instance is a reasonable
phase for the presentation of a single
atom well so what are you imagining
enter the instance of the carbon of a
carbon the material or what yeah of
carbon as an element
not as a material carbon as the
materials the other nozzle and then
something like a mount goes to one atom
basically okay I'm gonna make the
different proposal that we actually
consider having atom entities that
obviously crazy
maybe it's a silly idea what kind of
properties would with that domain have
that wouldn't be element properties they
would be I mean it would just it would
pretty much just go through two element
properties um cuz one thing that
occurred to me is I could set up a
number of entity stores that are that
ship with this pack lit and one of them
would be an atom entity so it wouldn't
need to be an entity type in the Wolfram
Alpha cares about that's just an
implementation detail I'm not worried
about that okay black is a property
unconvincing for a single atom yes
but the topic pages is a very good one
allotropes is unconvincing for a single
atom boiling point is unconvincing for a
single atom
and the hardness yeah I mean all about
properties are unconvincing for some I
mean interesting trust abundance is not
obviously stupid for single atoms so as
opposed to an entity last time we met
you you suggested having just an atom
wrapper around an association and if
that were the case that could format
nicely like if it were an atom atomic
symbol goes to a carbon mass number goes
fourteen then it would format as the C
with a fourteen superscripted beforehand
same with formal charge okay so we've
got two choices here we can either have
you know it's like we could either
decide that an atom is a conceptual
thing where we couldn't principle have
an atom with you know we should also
have presumably an atomic number if we
have an atom we should presumably have
an atomic number thing here we could
imagine the atom with atomic number 150
making sense I mean if we're gonna go
that direction then we should allow
ourselves the possibility of having
atoms that haven't been named and don't
aren't knowing therefore for example
isotopes that aren't know and isotopes
for two reasons a it's very power little
molecule and B even if we would have
atom as entities then there would be
still differences between a freestanding
atom in the universe and the atom vus in
a chemically all right there would be
yet so essentially we are turning you
know chemistry into mathematics here in
some sense we're defining an atom as an
abstract thing that has certain
attributes and we're not and knowing the
property of the atom like for example if
we know it's atomic you know it's atomic
number it's some its mass number you
know that specifies what type of atom it
is right but it doesn't tell us what its
actual atomic mass is and I'm making
sense right
and for example in this case we don't
know the actual atomic mass now we could
imagine that given an atom like this
that it would have certain properties
like atomic mass which when it is
computable from things we know we we
give it now for example we could imagine
you know is it stable for example is a
reasonable question to ask given a mass
number and so on so when you ask when
you say atom atomic number goes to 12
and then you want the atomic mass but
you have not specified the mass number
do you give the periodic table mass of
carbon which is a an average I think so
okay I don't think that's right for an
atom it should be
c12 receive 14 or c-13 specifically no
but we don't know it I mean we've got
the atomic number is 12 and we weren't
told the mass number okay then then it's
missing or not defined at this point I
don't think we should give an average I
don't think we should give it for still
average no because well hold on a second
I mean people most of the time are not
gonna give the mass number right the
time I'm in for carbon it's a little
weird but for for plenty of other
elements there are a bunch of knowing
isotopes and people routinely compute
you know molecular masses just based on
the you know the average isotopic
abundance right
the average isotope abundance is fine if
you're in the laboratory you need to
weigh out so many moles by mass for
molecular modeling purposes it's going
to be one isotope that gets tricky when
you're dealing with bromine and chlorine
where you have two isotopes that are
each around 40 percent abundant well so
what do you do you have to make your
choice at that point which one you're
going to model where you model an
ensemble of molecules okay on mass and
one with another mass right right so
let's take that as a for instance okay
so what you're saying is that in the
case of an iodine compound or something
that you're saying there are two
different
alekhya structures that you'll get
depending on which isotope of iodine
you're talking about is that right yes
and depending on the experiment you can
distinguish them rotational spectrum
spectroscopy for example microwave
spectroscopy would distinguish chlorine
35 from chlorine 37 in a molecule
oh what a mess well so far with the the
molecule implementation if you ask if
you create a molecule and you ask for
its smaller mass you get back what you
would get if you add it all everything
up from element data using the averages
using the atomic mass look I think I
think it's what we have to do I think
other anything else is just gonna be
obnoxious to the user now whether we
generate let's let's walk through this I
take this point Bob I take the point
that there's something complicated here
yeah and that basically what has to
happen you know in the case of iodine
for example you know who knows maybe
maybe it depends what part of the earth
you're on which one you know if they're
really close in in relative abundance um
I mean they're clearly other ones which
are really funky like uranium for
example where depending on whether
you're dealing with you know you might
be dealing with depleted uranium for
example where um you know where it's
been artificially the the abundances
have been artificially changed okay I
take that point but all right so listen
let's assume we're going to do the atom
wrapper which is going to be beautified
in some way it's probably got to have
its very own you know non yellow yellow
box so to speak
okay so then what you're saying is we're
talking about single bonds and so on and
you do you believe in the idea that like
two-way rule for example where if we
said two-way rule um we would have that
is something that has two arguments like
that and you're saying single bond is a
creature like that so that's your idea
yes okay and it's represented it has
some glyph and you're suggesting an
infix form for the glyph you
do we have a design for the glyph do we
know what the glyph will look like not
yet so I think it should look like the
undirected edge and then and then double
bond and triple bond would be like those
but with it's gonna stacked on each
other what about an aromatic bond Jason
well so one straight and then 1 dashed
underneath it just like they're they're
depicted in molecule plot right I think
in general they should be fairly long
glyphs
unlike the unlike undirected edge yeah
for example right yeah so with a knob at
the end either I think definitely okay
but still a clearly distinct from - in
that case then or - definitely yes
definitely but we can do that by having
okay the glyph makers so Andrei is in
charge of glyph making okay do we have
any project manager for this project
Jason's been acting is that okay well so
Jason you'll need to chase down on Draco
snark for the glyphs okay um and then in
terms of the installation of the glyphs
into the font that's a whole other
separate issue that goes through John
faults um but you can if you want to
know listen you could ask somebody like
Charles who about this because he's had
glyphs installed for graph theory stuff
he knows the procedure okay then we got
to go through here and you know I would
suggest certain access or functions have
got to work on Adam and others won't and
we probably should take those properties
from the element data and isotope data
okay so let's keep going
um all right so we have these various
bonds and okay now what on earth is this
creature here so we've we've moved back
and forth between having that
in the second argument or into an option
it's the its it describes the no I I
mean why is so when you describe a
molecule this is really pretty important
to knowing what molecule we're talking
about right I mean this is like this if
we have a graph and you failed to
represent you know have this it will be
like saying well I forgot to put in you
know so I don't think it's an option I
don't think that makes sense but now
let's walk through what this actually is
because I can't read this right now and
maybe this should turn into an
association it's a bit more readable so
walk me through what this means so that
is that means that the we're indexing
into elements of that list right great
and we're saying around this center in a
clockwise direction these things read in
that way is that correct with the caveat
that you need a direction in order to
define counter clockwise or clockwise so
the direction is given that you're
looking is from Adam to to Adam one how
do I know that it would be the
convention from the order specified but
if we use an association we could
specify those two particular atoms
references actually the first atom
stands by itself we could choose one
atom to be the fiducial atom which in
this case would be atom one and then the
remaining and then we would have a list
of remaining three atoms that would be
clockwise or counterclockwise okay
that's one way to do it it's kind of
long but I mean well let's just look at
this for a second okay
so but we could display this when we
display a molecule well we're displaying
the molecule as this molecule thing gets
displayed as a molecule that's the thing
that I don't like about this is it's
pretty cryptic I mean in other words
okay if people are gonna be seeing these
all the time they'll
what they mean but if people are only
gonna be seeing them oh whoops my
molecule has some weird stereochemistry
what on earth does that mean you know
and from the point of view of storage
and memory it doesn't make any
difference there all right well the way
it's handled pictorially in a
two-dimensional diagram is generally
with wedged were hashed bonds coming out
from an atom and two straight lines for
the two atoms that I've seen those right
okay so just roughly if you were gonna
write this out full form you know
explaining it having the structure
explain what's going on what would it
look like
I would probably if I were to make an
association I would say the first key
would be Center or atom or stereo Center
and then it would the value would be the
that particular atom its index or its or
its key you know of fiducial atom what
does that mean that's the reference atom
that you use to define the direction at
which you're going to look at the set of
atoms okay and then the third thing
would be a list of the other ligands
around the stereo center so that would
that key would probably be ligands okay
and the last item would be for
tetrahedral centers we can say parity
that's that is sometimes used and then
we would say clockwise or
counterclockwise for the value for that
which would indicate the direction that
the ligands describe when you follow
them in order looking from the fiducial
atom to the stereocenter atom
okay but now you're saying tetrahedral
but is that is that something we should
we should talk like stereotype or
something Tetris possibly for phase one
of this we want to only
handle tetrahedral centers or typical
organic chemistry once we get into
inorganic chemistry and we have five and
six coordinate atoms you still have
stereochemistry but it's not a binary
relationship it's not just an hour and
an S or a plus or minus you can have
different handedness and there are
several different arrangements around a
trigonal bipyramid
or an octahedron or square pyramid that
are different all right so you just
convinced me just from what you're
saying right now that we need to be a
little bit more careful here we need to
know we do time that's gonna generalize
to the case of beyond valence for yes we
do we knew we had to do that and maybe
having this stereotype is just what we
need to do that and I'm oh it it will
lend itself to the other type of
stereochemistry that we support at the
moment which is double bond
stereochemistry so there you have
stereotype goes to double bond or okay
yeah right okay and then eventually we
should also be able to handle chiral
axes and chiral planes which are another
whole beast and I'm not sure how we want
to do that but this would allow us to do
it fine then let's figure out the go
ahead how much are the properties of
these molecules versus poverty you can
randomly describe to any molecule so
most most molecules you'll find or not
most so a lot of times when you make
something in the lab you'll make both
handedness both parities in equal
measure but sometimes sometimes nature
has a strong preference what I mean
assume you have one that doesn't have
anything co2 or something like this but
you now start kind of putting this into
a molecule construct do you invalidate
this torch or is this still a topic or a
valid I don't think I don't think most
molecules don't have a multi-hundred
form it's my point right so I would I
would prefer to issue a message in
return on evaluated and let them delete
that bad
so what aspect of a molecule so given
this graph structure only certain Maalik
only certain atoms here
all valid stereocenters yes that's
correct and that's a computer property
you can ask for like say you don't give
any of the stereo elements you can ask
undefined stereocenters and i can tell
you which ones are possible stereo
centers and we have no handedness
attached to them or you could determine
the handedness from the 3d coordinates
oh that's interesting okay and they kept
it consistent fine I think this is the
way we should go but this kind of means
we need something like a molecule
molecule yeah yes what's the haters
always toy that definition yeah right so
yeah so we I mean I do have one hooked
up at the moment the molecule Q it's got
it it has a head of a molecule but it
isn't a molecule but the same is with
each and you can inside each an ABCD and
it's not reaching to you okay so here's
where we're gonna get in trouble we
can't have an atom Q because we've
already got one of those yeah and and
what does what happens if we've got you
know do we consider it an atom I mean
for example let's say there's a mass
number let's say the mass number is less
than the atomic number which is
impossible right what do we do B to
evaluate to something now that's crazy
never mind go ahead what you know say
issue a message to that effect in
pointing that if the problem and return
unevaluated yeah but we don't get to
have a function that asks is it a valid
my atom right so so far they had them
only lives inside the molecule yeah I
just wait they'll be out I mean some of
these things like like come okay so
another way we've got a bunch background
noise um
uh okay let's go back to this so what we
say so we've got an atom an on an
invalidation okay um atomic number a
hundred hundred and ten mass number you
know thirty okay totally impossible what
do we do
so I are you envision atom the way we're
describing it as being an inert as not
evaluating but if then if we apply
formatting rules to it then it will try
then at that point it'll say this is no
good maybe a good pink box I don't know
you know something like that a shame if
you don't have a way to polka matically
do something that you can do inductively
yes well I mean clearly um you know
valid atom or something can return true
or false
just like four or it's actually probably
a good idea because it is probably much
better than aq function because we don't
have the tools to do the nuclear
calculations if it's a valid atom like
you would force us to make a decision
but we can't do it yeah that's correct
and the same with molecule actually call
it okay so so then okay well I don't
know the valid is the right name maybe
it's physically realizable I mean that
the real word is physically realizable I
mean it's even beyond that because you
know clearly if we say carbon a hundred
right that is an isotope in principle it
wouldn't last very long you know
probably if you looked at the scattering
phase shift or something for the hundred
particles coming in they would be I
don't even know what would happen
Michael do you have a nuclear physics
comment on that no physically realizable
though implies perhaps some aspect of
energy or something like that that you
know created in the lab and a lot of
people recognize what we're doing here
as models rather than real molecules you
know in a bottle right but okay but
let's take the assam case to begin with
so we have a model for the atom you know
it has a mass number it has an atomic
number they have to satisfy certain
relationships well but there's a
different thing which is okay so there
is a much easier test which is no one
atom no an atom - yes
yep um that's fairly easy dancer maybe
also with some reservations
I guess the many nuclei they're known
but it's not clear if they ever had time
to form an atom that's true
um well so that's again subtle so I mean
basically what we need is an access or
that represents for both the atom and
the molecule case that represents maybe
the different conditions that could be
the case like for example one very clear
one is stable atom but that's a
definitely answerable thing um I mean
another thing that you could ask for
would be entity and it will return that
either the isotope or element entity
yeah fair enough but one thing so
depending determining whether these
things are valid or not doesn't
necessarily determine whether molecule
could eat them so presumably they could
contain blanks I mean at the moment I
haven't hook that up but they could but
I blame atomic number goes to blank um
oh gosh but we I haven't hooked up
queries multi patterns yet but okay well
that's a separate issue that's the
pattern atom so to speak as a separate
issue which we need to deal with I think
the answer to whether an atom with a
blank there as a stable atom is it's not
or it's not determined I mean the
correct thing is probably that it's not
determined all right let's keep going
here and I think that's a good solution
to that
okay so single argument constructors one
other thing I'd like to touch on there
if a user enters you know atomic number
six and does not specify the mass number
would we assume then that it's the most
stable one
well we're pushing earlier I mean I
think that yeah that the alternative
would be okay so here's an interesting
possibility okay um
we say atomic number six
well let's take what's iodine I don't
even know what some well whatever it is
that's permanent I know that's carpet oh
okay
that part I know lithium beryllium boron
carbon nitrogen oxygen fluorine neon oh
gosh it's gonna get take me too far to
get to iodine um we're all making sing
it you know right Rory good yeah so
could my youngest child um it's um okay
so okay but but but what I can imagine
here is that we do this now if you then
want to do molecular modeling there are
certain things that would then not work
but if you're doing you know molecular
mass type calculations that's gonna be
just fine right I think it's important
if somebody makes take caffeine as a as
a molecule it itch and you asked for it
smaller mass it should give the same
thing that would that the entity gives
you definitely which means that natural
abundance
even if then what has to happen is if
you've got things with natural abundance
which is what you probably get if it was
defaulted without a mass number
specified then I mean one thing that's
unfortunate about this okay so in a
perfect world this would be some kind of
discrete distribution actually no it
will be awaited what would it be it will
be some kind of weighted data type thing
where each of the actual numbers would
have an appropriate weight right I mean
that's the correct form for this um and
and this would just be a shorthand for
that and given this if you then try to
do molecular modeling your your basic
claim is we can't do molecular modeling
unless we have a definite well III don't
understand okay let me ask you guys
saying that that you can't do molecular
modeling it's just that depending on the
type of modeling you're doing
one use of the mass versus another
changes the result I understand so that
the stupid thing to do would be to say
if the you know if it's 12.2 is the
atomic mass I mean look they're two
different issues here one is the mass
number is not the atomic mass even
independent of because of the mass
defect and so on because of the binding
energy right so there's there's one
calculation is what is the actual mass
and the other calculation is what is the
mass taking into account the fact that
the mass number may be variable so I
mean this okay so the stupid thing to do
would be to say the effective mass of
the nucleus so the atom is 12.2 when
that is the thing you get by averaging
over multiple isotopes right right now I
don't people actually do that but maybe
that's just a dumb idea to do it that
way well so another so you put natural
abundance there and that's it would
default to the like element atomic mass
on the periodic table another thing that
you could write there would be this
probably the wrong name but communist or
most common I search a saying yeah
that's a good idea yeah you know and
that would be good for molecular
modelling in terms of spectroscopy or
something like that well so then maybe
the right thing to do is to say mass
number are automatic and that's the
default and when it's computing
molecular masses it does it by natural
abundance and when it's computing when
it's doing the modeling it does it by
communists that sounds good as long as
yeah I think we can make that workable
right so so when we give the the moment
of inertia tensor it's using the
specific isotope masses but if we got
all our mass it's it's what they write
okay and if you don't like that then you
pick atoms that are more specific right
you know that per deuterated compound
for example all the hydrogen's would
have you know mez number two right okay
I think this is good all right let's
move on single argument constructors
okay is this unique if the smiles the
smiles cannot
the name of the of the molecules that
correct in other words it seems
unfortunate to not be able to type
molecule of water I agree so okay so if
you type molecule of water but you miss
type it how can i if I don't know what
you meant it to be how can I give a good
message like I've added how do I know if
you mistyped a name or if you mistyped a
smile string our smile strings readily
recognizable very well I mean to a human
they're very recognizable I'm sure we
kept train I mean I wouldn't worry about
the miss typing thing if you mistyped it
you're on your own
remember it's gonna have auto completion
right so it's gonna be challenging to
miss type it right so we need an auto
completion table that is that works for
both names of molecules and smiles I
don't think we can do the ladder why we
just take common smiles and we also
complete to them if you're typing in
something which isn't a common smile
then keep typing that table will be
millions long okay well I mean so maybe
it has to go to the server to figure out
I mean if you're typing okay that is an
issue I mean we if you're typing a
hydrocarbon Steven how do you know when
you're going to stop you absolutely
don't but auto-completion is not a
mandate auto-completion is a suggestion
right and so you've typed four C's in a
row and that's butane and then it's
going to suggest pentane hexane heptane
you know odd infinitum uh well it
probably won't because it has look it
knows a certain probability distribution
for you know for these things so I mean
it's not going to keep suggesting them
forever um it's only gonna suggest the
common ones I don't know that that's
it's an interesting thought I hadn't
thought about it before I mean the
alternative is if it thinks you're
typing a smile doesn't know to suggest
anything it just gives up on the Auto
suggestion um
which i think is also okay and we only
also suggest common names right now
especially if it's mixed case like that
it'll be easy to tell because while
smiles does use lowercase letters it
won't look like a word
right but the generic name so
generically we'll assume it's a name is
that right even if that you will be able
to qualify it by saying molecule you'll
be able to say this is definitely a name
by saying name arrow
Slayton see I'm : or something or
whatever it is name no um and then you
could do the same by saying smiles arrow
and then give the smile string yeah okay
fair enough
or inchi or peptide sequence or
nucleotide sequence or something like
that and that's what these other bullets
are for okay sequence amino acids so
those are specifiable by random letters
of the alphabet right I think there's a
small subset of the letters that are
like so those are the single letter keys
20 amino acids you can't get away with
much less than the letters of the
alphabet right I mean for the bases so I
don't understand what um I mean I would
have expected that this would say
something like DNA sequence arrow a you
know something like this why would that
not be oh you got to say whether it's v
prime and so on is that right great
interpret is a protein sequence
yeah well fair enough but I don't think
you should do sequence and then a type I
don't see why we shouldn't just have
I think they're gonna be you know
justjust have these things and then
sequence arrow because the the left-hand
side is perfectly identifiable yes
that's fine by me
okay so what about the five Prime versus
three prime business what is that the
only thing you need to specify for a DNA
sequence to know where that molecule
actually is no reaction don't you spare
the end caps and weird stuff like that I
mean the thing isn't a real DNA sequence
is it if it you you can have a okay this
is showing my lack of knowledge but when
you have a fragment of DNA does it does
it need end cap it needs end caps right
to just hang out there otherwise it
unwrap it unravels doesn't it this is
this is also outside of my my scope also
all right okay well I can I'm pretty
sure about that so I think an amino acid
is you know a protein is different and
that's fine but I think what we want to
do there is I mean you're assuming that
they're all again I don't even know
whether you can mix left and
right-handed amino acids and so on are
bacteria you do okay Jason a we're
talking about this earlier today
well fine so we need some kind of
indicator then that's gonna be a little
bit of a mess right we'll need some kind
of indicator so it's no good to just say
L amino acid sequence or something we'll
check the IU pack rules for these
sequences and find notations that are
used okay let's keep going here include
hydrogen's so you made the point that a
oftentime een surely they would just be
there and it would be applauding or
display option but oftentimes people do
want to have and keen informatics want
to have just purely hydrogen suppressed
graph and so that wouldn't be the
default but it's it would be well so
what is the default the default is the
wouldn't include hydrogen's the default
is what all
what does that mean that every there are
no implicit four hydrogen's they're all
actual vertices in a list of vertices
fine fun fun fun
automatic would be there are some cases
where you need one hunt you need a
hydrogen in order to fill out your
valence but the rest can be implicit
okay fair enough and no so this is gets
gets away with previously I called it
the cool eyes option and so now it's
aromaticity model whether you whether
you detect aromaticity or whether you
mark them as single double alternating
bonds and then there we can supply some
some more subtle teases to the
aromaticity detection right so if
someone on the live stream is asking how
feasible is it to train a classifier on
different chemical format string types
absolutely feasible except that it has
some you know in the case where it's
just a single C or something there's
multiple answers um now they might all
agree in the case of multiple answers
that's an interesting possibility I
don't even know I mean in other words is
there are there puns between smiles you
know is is there a pun you know between
smiles and inchi other is there a smile
string that is also an entry string but
they mean a different molecule no so in
cheese always start with in chi equals
and so we wouldn't we could detect that
right off the bat I imagine you could
come up with something that is not a
chemically feasible molecule but is a
valid smiles and also is pronounceable
but I'm not it doesn't mean in general
to be clear in general people's major
escape valve is using our whole natural
language stuff where you just to typing
in I don't even know whether you can
give me a smiles to type in I'm just
gonna make up but I imagine a smile
might be and I might be completely wrong
and that's probably gonna conclude
something completely different but okay
whatever
the problem there what we do in alpha is
we you have to type in smiles first or
else the math parser really goes crazy
with with some of these big no cool well
I am is an actual chemical okay but so
so then I see well so that's a separate
issue is thinking we don't have to
address this issue let's see how the UI
looks because in the auto suggests we
could end up with something like for
example you know when we type RGB color
right we're getting a more sophisticated
autocomplete there all right see that
thing a choose color autocomplete if we
really think this is important we could
have a whole elaborate thing yeah I mean
we can even have something there that
allows you to start drawing molecules
and so on for making sense
there would be that would be fantastic
that we could do that right I mean so we
can pull up this kind of interface right
to choose colors so why not have an
interface that allows you to draw the
molecule in principle if we if we had
such an interface and that would allow
us to governor escape valve to do much
more sophisticated you know natural
language pausing if we need to yep
something like the graph edit
yes right okay so metro information uses
wide Association fine um we've got that
in other places so I have no idea what
any of this means but arum aromaticity
model sounds sensible to me
okay coordinates let's take a look at
that
so it's inherently going to be a little
trickier than graph because you're
interested in both 2d and 3d one option
would be to say that a molecule can only
have one set of coordinates and it's
either 2d or 3d but that seems limiting
that's silly you might want both
possible displays right I mean the 2d
coordinates a schematic exactly Jason
that's the term we need to use instead
of disk depiction was what I was saying
depiction schematic is the better word
so schematic coordinates something like
that well okay I'm not sure that that's
quite right and I don't think vertex
coordinates right even though that's the
chemical data property for the 2d
coordinates because in the graphs
probably should change we can we can
have an additional property without any
trouble um skew Matic is the right
adjective okay
well but it has connotations of an
electronic circuit indeed um let's see
do we want to say coordinates is that
even the right term it's not really
coordinates its atom atom positions or
something isn't it because what what are
the you know where's the zero it's some
kind of atom relative positions but
we're not I mean we're not we're not
giving the relative like the internal
coordinates we're like we're pretty
putting it in space well I understand
that but where's the zero when we
generate the coordinates we put the zero
at the center of mass okay fine so you
you think then that that's a reasonable
coordinate system what about that what
about the rotational aspect of the
coordinate system so you can
canonicalize it by taking the principal
axes and aligning them with the
Cartesian axes and then a few other
rules on top of that can be applied as
well for symmetrical molecules okay so
there is a canonical coordinates when we
say if we said canonical coordinates
it'll remind me
quantum mechanics and be totally
confusing but um if you want them to be
able to to move them to do a geometric
transformation and change those
coordinates so that you could look at
show two molecules together yeah that's
especially important when you're trying
to dock a small molecule into a receptor
or an enzyme okay all right so then
there's an atom coordinates that is and
so now the issue is what would it be
cold
what are you cold above the 2d diagram
we typically call the structure a
structure diagram you know he's an
organic chemist though that's what we
would call it and that's the chemical
data property for the picture okay yeah
I like that it's it's it's clear what
that is and what the difference is so
could we say structure diagram
coordinates then yeah that's what I'm
suggesting here okay all right what the
heck is a random seat that is scary as
heck users might want to generate a
different structure okay so we've got
this option random seating which is the
thing that determines how that works
we've used that a bunch of other
functions okay there would be the option
for stochastic method to generate the
coordinate right but now notice these
three cases right it's either automatic
which means it's reseeded every time
it's called inherited which means it's
using the stream of randomness that is
defined by things like block random on
the outside or it's using an explicit
seed that makes sense and that's quite
useful because being able to do it you
want all of those cases right no we do
so I believe that there's a case in is
it in the neural networks where it when
it says it has an option I I don't know
if it's random seeding or if it's a
string valued random seed but it
specifically says what they use that in
order for reproducibility when I called
my life regenerate yes that's right
absolutely that's what I mean
I made a big fuss about that because
was all confused I mean it's a little
bit weird we use I think we used one two
three four or something right I use
stupid there we go
right okay so into so so I could switch
to using that I use I use 42 because the
Hitchhiker's Guide but it's cute but I
would use one two three four okay I
think I think it's much clearer if you
see one two three four in the output
it's kind of yeah you know it's just
some 42 you might get confused it's some
atomic mass of something you know it
yeah it starts spinning out of control
um okay so what is this this is Adam
coordinates to automatic what is Adam
embedding well so in graph they have two
different functions in two different
options one vertex coordinates when you
specifically provide them but then
there's graph layout which you can graph
layout it's gonna have a lot more
methods and a lot more named methods
than we will but you could you could
give options to the to the embedding
what do you mean why are we calling so
in a minute the Adam coordinates if you
don't know the Adam coordinates there's
two cases either you know them or you
don't know them well me you might know
some of them but not all of them right
but why don't you just have a way of
specifying Adam coordinates either that
you know them and it's some particular
thing in picometers or whatever it
whatever it's in and is it in picometers
or what well that's where we're using
coordinate array or quantity array okay
so it is in Pico meters angstroms is the
normal okay yeah um so much for si si
give up on that or is si still fighting
for Pico meters there to be compatible
for right now okay so we'll wait another
50 years
chemists just want the the bond length
to be around one so so so put any
options for the generation of of
coordinates in to use the same option
value atom coordinates it could be XO
okay I think so and I think as it
canonical eise's
I mean what is gonna cause it to jump to
actual coordinates to computed molecular
you know modeling coordinates so they're
lazy so you would have so if you create
it and you don't provide them and you
just end with a semicolon
we haven't computed them yet and only
when you ask for them do do we compute
them is that what you're asking
I'm sorry sorry sorry I spaced out for a
second could you could you repeat so so
the the atom coordinates are
instantiated when you ask for them when
you did when you display it okay but are
they are they then stored after that or
not so we would like them to be but I
don't know how to do that because that
implies making it mutable well not if
that cached well so they're cached but
but then when you they're cached within
the kernel session but then when you if
you quit the kernel and start over
you're going to have to so Rican well in
that case you've got to return a
different molecule right you've got to
have something then we've probably got
to have something that says what's an
analogy to this well I mean there is a
strange analogy there is a thing that we
just added to proneural nets for a
current neuron that's called a little
bit of a different thing it's a net
state object where it's used for
reinforcement learning and so on where
the thing learns by doing so to speak
where it changes we're okay so that's it
that's another issue so we've got to
have some function that that's compute
stuff for the molecule and returns a new
molecule with things computed in we
don't have that issue in graph because
we think we can do the graph layout fast
enough that we don't need to bother to
cache it is that correct you don't have
to cache a bit across kernel sessions I
assume as they cache them within don't
know should ask I don't really know so
Michael and I were just talking today
about wanting some function that was
instantiate all the ephemeral options
like but we couldn't come up with a name
but but Michael yeah I understand I
understand I mean that's I mean we also
don't have much precedent for this
behavior in the system also I think
there would be places where we could
make use of this yeah to instantiate the
canonicalized form of something I mean
we could always have a canonical form
yeah I don't like it
canonicalize blah I don't really like it
so essentially you want to take every
every option that was going to automatic
and so you want to have like a real
absolute options which doesn't yes I
mean but absolute options just absolute
option values or something change object
what no it does not return a new object
well I mean canonicalize is a beginning
of that but I think that in some cases
let's we're not gonna get that resolved
today bring that back next time um let's
just keep going here for a moment I'm
going to have to unfortunately go again
um do we still have a chance to discuss
this tomorrow or are you guys off by
tomorrow I'm off tomorrow okay well
let's see how far we can get right I do
unfortunately have to go soon so as far
as formatting goes it I said it's not
really possible to make something like a
summary box but without the molecule but
I do believe that by release I should be
able to work out the code for the
attached cell I really like the
interactivity that mesh regions have
with that attached cell and so it seems
was in the cloud okay um I do not know
yeah so your proposal then would be to
actually return essentially the molecule
plot as the displayed form of a molecule
is that right right and then one of the
options would be to say turn this into a
3d plot or - well that is molecular plot
molecule plot 3d would presumably be the
3d version rate rate but um but when
when you're just interacting with the
object itself outside of the plot you
could switch from 2d to 3d form mmm I
mean another thing we were thinking was
you could have it display as a summary
box but then have a chemical form slash
slash chemical form and it would it
would give you a more interactive object
well I have another question which is I
mean I'm not in this business so I don't
know whether when you see this okay you
see some big molecule it turns out to be
caffeine but you put in you said
molecule of quotes caffeine and out came
this big complicated structure diagram
right do you then say oh my gosh that's
really useless I can't tell what that is
I prefer to just see the word caffeine
why did it have to show me the structure
diagram you know instead of just showing
me caffeine now I
could also argue if I type in 2 to the
power 100 it produces an actual number
and you might say well it'd be more
useful to see to the power 100 than to
see this long number but that's I mean
my question is if you're a chemist and
the thing just produces the structure
diagram do you say ok great that's a
nice representation of my molecule or do
you say oh I was missing the name so
with the Nate with the name do we store
that name do should we put it in the
meta information so right now if you say
name goes with Dennison triphosphate I
convert that into a structure and then
throw away the name well but if I ask
for the name right so so I could put
that name goes to that in the meta
information I would I mean I think well
I think that's a good idea for most
cases that people would be using it for
and if they start to edit the molecule
then the name might become questionable
and they could at that point say mall
meta information unset if they wanted to
yeah or they yeah um I am going to have
to go unfortunately drat
I would love to continue this um we've
made a lot of progress today this is a
beautiful thing I mean this is gonna be
fantastic
I want to see some of these things wow
this is really cool
so once we've got this design stuff
straightened out um how long until
you've got this fully implemented I mean
is this is the is the underlying
structure here basically implemented and
we're doing some cosmetics here or is
there a lot of underlying structure that
still has to be built
a little of both I've what I've written
so far is flexible enough that I can
change the design but I've left some
things in the air because waiting for to
nail down the designed to really flesh
them out yeah I mean this stuff here I'm
not you know I don't know about and I
also another question I would ask is you
know when you have multiple molecules
like you talked about you know docking
of molecules how are we representing
that what is the you know is there some
kind of molecular cluster thing that
represents you know like the analog of I
don't know what what the idea would be
but boy you've got two molecules and
they've got coordinates atom coordinates
that are relative to their joint center
of mass or whatever else it is right we
certainly I mean UK the object can
support having disconnected structures
in one module molecule but really it's
actually this drug binding to this
particular site right but but I would if
would it would be nice if there were
some kind of scene or something like I'm
out there you could well it's a little
weird when you've got ten water
molecules dancing around and it's a
overall thing is wrapped in a molecule
right and especially in the phase two or
three when when we can hook up some
molecular dynamics and you make a box
and you put a thousand water molecules
in it and you put your protein in it
certainly that thing is not a molecule
yeah maybe we could use ensemble I don't
think that's used in the system anywhere
not but I think but ensemble you know
for the PI system
yeah right it implies the other thing
that those might be called is if its
water molecules it would be called a
cluster yeah right or gas molecules but
with you know like a protein and ligands
or a protein and some small number of
water molecules that are hydrating the
active site for example we do need a
container for that because you know
strictly speaking it's not a molecule
right but so look the point is that this
is similar to what happens in system
modeler where you have multiple you know
mechanical thing
and I don't know what that rapper how
that rapper works there but that's what
we should be looking at yeah I can talk
to Patrick right fine okay
this is looking really lovely um I mean
I'm I'm very much looking forward to the
next step I assume I assume next week
everybody is out I'm actually around so
okay oh well all right so I guess this
waits for the new year but if you want
to you know it's conceivable we could do
some stuff without bubble though I would
prefer not to um if it's holding you up
Jason we should do that but if it isn't
then let's wait for Bob to be back right
I can spend next week kind of
implementing this and there's some some
code cleanup that I would want to do and
if I have questions I can start an email
list with the four of us on it fine
sounds good all right look forward to
the next step though maybe we should try
and schedule at least an hour and a half
for the next meeting possibly even two
hours this is this is this still quite a
bit of complexity here right okay
okay see you guys soon